rosie is with us in Florida hi Rosie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up in your world thank you for taking my
call my pleasure I have a question so
I'm a nurse
and I have a car that I bought and it
was the worst decision ever so now I'm
trying to get rid of it but I got bad
equity on it around 17,000 I was 39,000
on it so my husband and I has been
discussing because I mrs. gazelle
intense he doesn't get yet but um I what
what his idea was because I've been
paying on a dead I paid it around three
days already and he's like well before
you pay the other one let's tape down
this car so we can get rid of it
but I worked I'm a nurse so I worked my
part-time job I go to my clients so I'm
putting a lot of mileage on it and I
don't want it when I'm able to sell it I
don't want it to have to sell it for
less because I'm putting mileage on it
so his idea was let's buy $3,000 car put
this one in the garage
pay it off paid down to the amount we
owe and then sell it and get rid of that
debt so what do you think about that you
owe 39 on it it's worth 17 less than
that yes
is $22,000 you must have rolled negative
equity from your other deal into this
one I did because I mean cars go down in
value fast but not usually that fast
mm-hmm so what kind of car is this is
rad for 2018 and who said it's worth 22
I went to Kelly Blue Book and our
private sellers than 23-thousand 23 okay
all right so you probably rolled 10,000
negative into it to start with yes okay
and what is your total household income
I make 65 we make around ninety five
thousand but in my second job that I had
I'd be making up making almost the same
amount of but I'm making on my regular
job so what is the total household
income with you working the second job I
was around 120 very good okay
what other debts do you have other than
this car I have a home depot car that is
only have $4,000 on it which is I'm
working on it at what else I have it I
have ninety five thousand on student
loans my husband doesn't have any penny
your husband has all this debt he
married you I know that's right that's
right he knows you know so we're working
together the entire household income you
have to be working together you're not
gonna get out if you don't work together
we are now I have a question for you how
do I get my husband it came from the
Dominican Republic and he's a
spanish-speaking so it's hard for me to
get him like I'm all riled up because I
keep here I'll keep listening to the
program on my way to work and everywhere
but he's not so he doesn't really
understand I mean he's very good with
money he tries to you know pay debt and
stuff but he doesn't know exactly the
Cross the program that I was following
because he doesn't he doesn't speak
English he only treats panic remember
this name look up Andres Gutierrez I'm
dressed as a young man Hispanic young
man that does all of our material in
Spanish actually has a talk radio show
that's on in about 30 or 40 cities out
of San Antonio and sharp young guy and
he probably got some stuff on YouTube
he is the talent we actually have
Financial Peace University in Spanish
and he's the speaker oh yeah okay I
couldn't do it because hillbilly Spanish
doesn't work but so you guys let me do
this I'll just what I'll do is I'm gonna
give you the total money makeover in
Spanish I'll mail that to you and then
you check out the rest of the stuff and
you and your husband get on the same
page because if you take a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars and you start
attacking you knock out that home depot
card real fast you're gonna knock out
that seventeen thousand really really
it's not gonna take you long it's just a
matter of a few months so do you think
it's wise to part the car and not you
think no no because I think you're gonna
be if you're both on track here I mean
making a hundred and twenty you should
pay off like you're seventeen and your
four is twenty-one you should be on
track to pay off sixty thousand a year
so thirty thousand every six months so
you should do this in just four or five
months your car and your home depot card
okay and you're not gonna put that much
miles on it in four or five months okay
if you were gonna wait two years and run
up a fifty thousand miles on it or
something I would agree with this plan
but I want you to get I want you two to
get on the same page and get out of debt
faster than that so hold on I'll have
Madison pick up and we'll send you a
Spanish version of the Total Money
Makeover and that'll help him you guys
get on the same page and work together
on this which is absolutely vital to
winning